der
S
So, wann ist denn das Lebenslaufdienst?
Als nächstes, morgen kann ich es nicht machen, also heißt es am Wochenende höchstwahrscheinlich.
Ich hoffe mal Samstag.
Samstag ist immer ein ganz guter Tag für neue Bits.
Heute machen wir keinen Köpernätis, nee, heute machen wir gar nichts.
Ich habe heute ein bisschen so wie der Köpernätis gebastelt.
Ich habe mal versucht ein GitLab zu hausten in Köpernätis.
Leute ich sage euch, das ist abfucked, das ist selbst hausten.
Ich weiß schon warum man sowas normalerweise nicht selbst hausten will.
Ich weiß nicht, an mir liegt es nicht.
In dem Fall liegt es nicht an mir, bei den letzten Videos hat es immer an mir gelegen.
Kurz gucken ob heute noch irgendwie Kreisel, Grind, MMO ist, aber die waren bis jetzt alle
nicht da, deswegen vermute ich mal nicht.
Nee, nix, kein Kreisel, Grind.
Leute es ist wirklich, du findest GitLab mittlerweile fürchterlich, weiß gar nicht, ich kann dazu
nicht viel sagen.
Ich habe GitLab selbst ewig nicht benutzt, aber ich dachte mir so, warum hauen wir nicht
einfach mal in meinen lokalen Köpernätis Cluster.
Das ist im Prinzip auch einfach, leider funktioniert wieder ein paar Sachen nicht und das ist ewig
abfucked das rauszukriegen.
Zum Beispiel ist da Standard Runner Container verbuckt und du musst erstmal ein paar Helmchart
Werte überschreiben, dass der mit dem Ubuntu Image und nicht mit einem Alpine Image startet,
weil das Alpine Image hat DNS Auflösungsprobleme.
Da gab es witzigerweise erst vor kurzem ein Hacker News Alpine Post, never use again oder
sowas hieß das, I will never use again Alpine Linux und das war mir so auch gar nicht ganz
klar.
Alpine hat Probleme, wenn DNS Anfragen größer als 512 Bytes sind, also bzw.
DNS Request größer sind als 512 Bytes, der gesamte Request, nicht nur die Anfrage und
da muss man sagen, das wusste ich nicht und das ist ziemlich scheiße, weil je nachdem
was so ein DNS Server return, kann man durchaus schon mal über 512 Bytes kommen, ich meine,
wenn das Ding erstmal MX Records, vier weitere Server und haste nicht gesehen returned, dann
gibt es auf einmal doofes DNS Problemen, von denen man nichts wusste und jetzt hat lustigerweise
der GitLab Runner auch Probleme gehabt, den ich installiert habe mit Alpine Linux und
dann geht es weiter, dann funktioniert beim Runner natürlich kein Docker in Docker, weil
es ist ja quasi schon ein containerisierter Workload und sowas, es ist alles, ist alles
ein bisschen eklig.
Ne, ich wollte halt mal so ein komplettes System draufklatschen, ich dachte mir, hey,
die haben so einen Helm Chart zum installieren, haust du mal drauf, ist tatsächlich unglaublich
bescheuert gemacht, also, ja, das ist wieder viel zu kompliziert.
Ne, heute kein Kubernetes-Stell, das kriege ich heute auch nicht noch auf die Reihe, ich
habe tagsüber ein bisschen, ein bisschen Kubernetes gestellt und da habe ich jetzt
keinen Bock drauf mehr, ich mal gucken, ich meine, realistisch ist es eh nicht, warum
sollte man GitLab in einem Kubernetes-Cluster selbst haust, macht ja eigentlich jetzt relativ
wenig Sinn.
GitLab entwickelt sich auch super langsam, bei denen sind Issues zweierhand, gut, das
ist aber normal, bei größeren Projekten, die kriegen ja tausende Issues oder hunderte
Issues, die kannst du gar nicht alle fixen und kennt ihr, kennt ihr so GitLab, nein nicht
GitLab, GitHub, GitHub-Projekte, was ist denn mit der Musik wieder los, warum ist hier zweimal
so laut?
Leute, ich brauche was, ich brauche Relaxing, hier, das da jetzt, ja, besser, kennt ihr,
kennt ihr größere Open Source oder generell GitHub-Projekte, es wird, es wird dann YouTube
geschaut, ja, oder zumindest teilweise, The brutal downfall of, ach, er wieder, der hat,
der hat schon lange keinen, von dem haben wir schon lange nichts mehr geguckt, ja, was
ich sagen wollte, kennt ihr die GitHub-Projekte, die so einen automatischen, ich schließe
das Issue-Bot drinne haben, das ist das Unsinnigste überhaupt und das fuckt mich jedes Mal ab,
du suchst nach irgendeinem Fehler, findest was über Google, stellst fest, oh, das ist
sogar ein Ticket schon offen in dem Projekt, was verbackt ist, guckst rein, Auto close
nach 30 Tagen, nichts wurde gemacht, nichts wurde reagiert, es ist so hängen geblieben,
deswegen mache ich das, deswegen mache ich das auch nicht, der 4 Champ wird Issues aufhaben
bis 2045, wenn es keinen mehr interessiert, ich werde den Kram nur closen von Hand oder
halt fixen, wobei ich gerade keinen Bock habe, ja, Auto close nach 30 Tagen ist richtig,
richtig blöd, ne, machen wir heute gar nicht, heute gucken wir ein bisschen, heute schwätzen
wir ein bisschen, gucken ein paar Videos, es ist ja auch nur noch quasi fast knapp 2 Stunden
Zeit, ja, aber das finde ich total bescheuert, die Auto close Geschichten, die da manche
machen, Docker in Docker im Runner funktioniert, ja, aber das funktioniert nicht so ohne weiteres,
wenn dein Runner in einem Kubernetes Cluster läuft, wenn dein Runner in einem Kubernetes
Cluster läuft, musst du als erstes den Container privileged ausführen und dann irgendwelche
Environment Variablen setzen und das hat bei mir nicht funktioniert, wobei es eigentlich
eine ziemlich doofe Idee ist, den privileged Container im Kubernetes Cluster auszuführen
und da irgendwie Docker Zeug freizugeben, ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet für Zugriff
auf den Kubernetes Cluster selbst, das klingt zumindest nicht nach einer guten Idee, kann
er denn jeder den Kubernetes Cluster ausschalten oder so, das klingt jetzt eben nicht so sinnig,
ich muss auch sagen, ich finde es gar nicht mal großartig sinnvoll, ja, wie habt ihr
das gemacht, ja Moment, ihr baut Docker Images in Kubernetes, ja gut, ich will bilden, das
da will ich machen, also wie gesagt, GitLab selbst braucht, also GitLab selbst sagt, man
muss den Container privileged starten und irgendwie Zugriff auf den Cluster geben, was
irgendwie an sich schon ziemlich komisch ist, ach so, Docker in Docker, ja, Docker in Docker
funktioniert, das ist, das ist, keine Ahnung, weiß nicht was, das kenne ich nicht, aber
ich will das ja gar nicht wirklich machen, ich wollte es ja heute nochmal ausprobieren,
weil an sich finde ich es ziemlich unsinnig, ehrlich gesagt, da hast du nämlich irgendwie
so ein Henne-Ei Problem, also wenn du alles in einem Cluster über irgendeinen Git Repo
laufen lässt, was dann selbst wiederum im Kubernetes Cluster gehorchtet ist und mal
irgendwas geht kaputt, dann ist das Repo nicht da, du kannst keine Änderungen machen, das
ist alles ein bisschen unsinnig, also wenn schon sollte das ein extra Cluster sein oder
ganz ehrlich, nehmt einfach irgendeinen gehosteten Service und gut ist, wenn man eh schon in
der Cloud unterwegs ist, warum sollte ich den, warum sollte ich den Kram selbst hosten,
wenn es was fertiges gibt und man hat sich, und man hat sich schon dafür entschieden,
dass man Cloud Services benutzt, wenn man alles offline machen will, ganz ehrlich, dann würde
ich schlicht und ergreifend eine VM hinhauen und gut ist, dass das unabhängig davon ist,
weil den Cluster-Managen über ein System, was selbst im Cluster läuft, ist immer ein
bisschen, bisschen doof, außerdem finde ich, außerdem muss ich sagen, war es ziemlich
kompliziert bisher.
Was sind gute Weiterbildungen für Fachinformatiker, was, du meinst für wie, Fachinformatiker
System-Integrations-Azubis, also Integration wird zwar mit I geschrieben, aber trotzdem,
kommt drauf an, was dich interessiert, was interessiert dich denn, sag mal, was dich
für einen Bereich interessiert, das kann man pauschal nicht sagen, man, du kannst alles
und nichts machen.
Nee, mach ich nicht, ist das irgendein VR-Ding oder mal das exte Remake von Resident Evil
4 oder die exte Neuauflage.
Das Drama habe ich übrigens auch nur am Rande mitbekommen, um GTA oder GT, wie man das ausspricht,
die wurden von irgendeinem, von irgendeiner Firma in Hongkong nicht übernommen, sondern
irgendeine Hongkonger, China-Chinesen-Firma will jetzt Support dafür anbieten oder sowas,
es gab einen riesigen Shitstorm, sein riesigen Shitstorm ist vielleicht übertrieben, nicht
zu verwechseln oder zu vergleichen mit dem Wizard-Game-Shitstorm, das hat deutlich mehr
Leute interessiert, als das, wenn Leute irgendwas forken.
Und jetzt gibt es irgendwie einen Fork, der weiterhin, der wird irgendwie von Codeberg
entwickelt, kein Schimmer, was da wieder abgeht, man, wenn der Friseur da mal wieder Bock hat.
Kannst du Zed und Reckaxe gut, ja, geht ganz gut, ja, Zed-Syntax ist aber abartig und du
kannst auch nicht alle Reckax-Schweinereien in Zed machen.
Welche, gab es wieder neue, ich kenne nur die 4-Chan-Leaks, dass es wieder, dass es
in der Zeit 2020 bis 2030 spielen soll und also, dass es nicht mehr ganz so futuristisch
ist, dass es wieder ein Single-Player haben soll und boah, weiß ich gar nicht, ja, genau,
genau, Battle Royale zum Start, ja, mal gucken, ganz ehrlich, 4-Chan-Leaks haben ja schon
ab und zu mal gestimmt, kann durchaus sein, klingt doch sinnvoll, ich meine gerade das
mit dem Battle-Royale-Modus für Battlefield 7 klingt insofern sinnvoll, weil der neue
Battlefield-Chef ja der von Apex Legends ist und der hat halt Erfahrung mit Battle-Royales
und die Leute haben schon lange nach einem Battle-Royale geschrien, zumal Warzone 2
nicht so gut läuft, wie es sein könnte, vielleicht haben sie die Hoffnung, so aus diesem Modern-Warfare-Military-Bereich
ein paar Leute abzugreifen und das könnte durchaus klappen, also wenn das gescheit ist,
ich traue halt DICE nicht mehr zu, dass sie was gescheites machen.
128 Spieler Battle Royale, das würde ich durchaus verstehen, das klingt irgendwie sinnig
je nach Karte, aber normale Spielmodi weiß ich nicht, ob 128 nicht so sinnvoll ist, das
hängt aber auch ein bisschen von den Karten ab und wie die Spotting-Mechanik und alles
funktioniert.
In Battlefield 2042 ist es ja aktuell so, dass dich jeder dahergelaufener Dude irgendwie
spotten kann.
Und dann ist es natürlich schwierig, wenn du 64 Spieler hast, die auf dich gucken können
potenziell.
Habt ihr Vorschläge, wie man sein eigenes BIOS pricken kann, für ein Notebook, auf
das man Wut hat?
Da gibt es was viel einfacheres, selten von sowas.
Also wenn du ein Notebook kaputt machen willst, dann kannst du es auch richtig kaputt machen,
dann machst du es doch richtig kaputt, warum willst du das BIOS pricken, das wird wahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren.
Also wenn das ein halbwegs gescheites Notebook ist, wird das wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Hä?
Muss was mit geprägtem BIOS anfangen, ich check mich, was los ist.
Ist es schon geprägt oder willst du es pricken?
Hä?
Das gibt es jetzt, das ist unverständlich.
Du willst es pricken, ja du willst dein Notebook kaputt machen, warum haust du es nicht kaputt?
Also ich könnte mir einfachere Varianten vorstellen, ein Notebook zu zerstören, als
das BIOS zu pricken.
Oder hat es einen Grund, warum du ausgerechnet das BIOS pricken willst und nicht das Ding
kaputt machen willst?
Man kann es einfach absehen, dass es wahrscheinlich gar kein BIOS mehr ist.
Also wie gesagt, Force Power Off wird wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren, es ist gar nicht so einfach
ein BIOS zu pricken, nein, vielleicht kannst du im BIOS-File mit dem Hex-Editor herumsauen
und das dann flashen, falls er keinen Checksum-Überprüfung macht oder sowas.
Tja, dann fällt mir das so spontan auch nichts ein.
Die Dinger sind ja absichtlich so gemacht, dass man sie relativ schwer pricken kann,
weil sonst das Notebook nicht mal bootet.
Tja, nee, keine Ahnung, fällt mir jetzt nichts ein.
Die Leute sind einfach nicht mehr da.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht, warum sie es nicht gebacken kriegen.
Nein, das wird bei den meisten nichts bringen, großartig, Strom rausziehen.
Das steht zwar immer da, Achtung, bitte nicht den Strom abschalten, aber bei den meisten
passiert dann gar nichts.
Das ist eine gute Frage, da kann ich mal meinen Senf zugeben, auch wenn ich noch nicht
alle Cloud-Plattformen wirklich jetzt so ausführlich benutzt habe.
Also, ich kenne mich mit Azure am besten aus.
Ach, Moment, ich habe mich verlesen, ich habe gelesen, Azure, AWS oder GCP, ich habe mich
verlesen, ich dachte du willst wissen, welche Cloud-Plattformen ich am besten finde.
Nee, okay, du willst wissen, würdet ihr für Infrastructure bei AWS eher Terraform oder
CDK nutzen oder doch, ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ich kenne das Amazon eigene Zeug nicht,
ich habe das noch nicht verwendet.
Ich würde allerdings persönlich eher zu Terraform tendieren, weil du mit Terraform auch andere
Sachen machen kannst und nicht so sehr an diesen eigenen Cloud-Anbieter gebunden bist.
Und dann lernst du halt auch was für die Zukunft, ja klar, du kannst sagen CDK, dann lernst
du auch was für die Zukunft, aber die Zukunft heißt dann auf jeden Fall AWS, also ich würde
mir auf jeden Fall Terraform angucken und ich würde wahrscheinlich Terraform auch vorziehen,
das liegt aber daran, weil ich auch mit anderen Cloud-Plattformen als AWS was machen will,
mit AWS mache ich eigentlich am wenigsten, bei AWS blicke ich immer nicht durch, wie
die einzelnen Dinger heißen, die haben dann Fargate und sowas, was soll Fargate sein?
Fargate ist glaube ich der Managed Kubernetes Service von Amazon und so Dinger, die haben
Namen, da blickst du überhaupt nicht durch, nee, da blickt auch AWS nicht durch, also
die Benamungen sind, bei Google Cloud habe ich jetzt gesehen, ich habe mich jetzt in
letzter Zeit öfters ein bisschen mit Google Cloud beschäftigt, da geht es zum größten
Teil, also die Hosted Postgres Dinger heißen dann auch Hosted RDB oder irgendwie sowas,
also da muss ich sagen, das Teufel bei Google ist eigentlich ganz sinnvoll benannt, bei
Azure geht es auch einigermaßen, das kann sein, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht, aber
es ist auf jeden Fall wirbel, das Teufel bei Amazon benannt ist, da blicke ich nicht
durch, das muss ich sagen, ich habe auch schon ein bisschen in letzter Zeit mit Pulumi rumgespielt,
finde ich persönlich viel angenehmer als Terraform, ich bin aber zumindest froh, dass Terraform
kein Yammel verwenden kann, wobei kann Terraform nicht sogar mittlerweile Yammel, anscheinend
können die auch Yammel mittlerweile, also ich bin ja eigentlich ganz froh, dass Terraform
kein Yammel verwendet, weil Yammel geht mir auch in letzter Zeit zunehmend auf den Sack,
man ist ja bald kein DevOps Engineer mehr oder kein Anwendungsentwickler mehr oder kein
Admin mehr, sondern man ist eher Yammel Engineer, weil alles mittlerweile nur noch in Yammel
ist, und Yammel ist so kacke zu lesen und Yammel ist so verbose, das ist so lang alles,
du schreibst alles 30 mal hin und ich bin kein großartiger Yammel-Fan, ja gut, du kannst
es manchmal nicht aussuchen, wenn du halt Tools verwendest, die Yammel-Config haben,
dann ist Yammel-Config das Einzige, was du machen kannst und selbst wenn nicht, selbst
wenn es dafür dann irgendwelche Tommel-Möglichkeiten gibt, ist halt die Frage, ob das irgendwas
Community-Maintainedes ist, wo dann morgen kein Support mehr gibt, ist das irgendwas,
was die auch die anderen verstehen, wenn man mit diesem Service nur Yammel gewöhnt ist,
also eins muss ich sagen, eins hab ich die letzten Jahre über gelernt, es ist sinnvoll,
sich an Defaults zu halten, beziehungsweise so wenig wie nötig von den Defaults abzuweichen,
einfach der Klarheit halber und nachdem das manchmal so kompliziert werden kann, alles,
was man macht, ist es sinnvoll, wenn man bei Defaults bleibt, wenn möglich, dann hast du
auch nicht das Problem, dass du irgendwie ein Custom Plugin brauchst von irgendeinem
Third-Party-Typ, der dann in zwei Monaten keinen Bock mehr hat, weil wenn man sich mal
anguckt, wie Zusammengestücke manche Services mittlerweile sind, die bestehen aus 180 verschiedenen
Einzelteilen und Produkten und alles lässt sich ein bisschen anders konfigurieren und
sowas, da bin ich mittlerweile auf dem Standpunkt, dass ich sage, hä, manchmal ist es sogar sinnvoll,
nicht auf ein bisschen Funktionalität zu verzichten, wenn man es halt nicht zwingend
braucht und lieber bei dem Default zu bleiben und das, was mitgeliefert wird, als noch drei
zusätzliche Plugins, die dann noch mal extra konfiguriert werden müssen, das ist richtig,
wie gesagt, mir hat das auch gut gefallen, also ich persönlich würde, wenn ich die Auswahl
habe, die Sachen auch lieber in Pulumi machen als in Terraform, das stimmt, Terraform lässt
sich nicht eins zu eins transferieren, also alles sieht anders aus, vor allem liegt es
halt auch daran, weil die Dinger unterschiedlich heißen, es heißt halt bei AWS anders als bei
Azure oder bei GCP und dann heißt das halt auch in Terraform anders, weil die Cloud-Anbieter
den Kram halt unterschiedlich benennen, ja gut, ist halt so, aber man kann sich zumindest
dran gewöhnen, wie man Terraform an sich verwendet, von der Syntax her, wie man Schleifen
macht und sowas, man Schleifen, was auch immer die sich da ausgedacht haben, aber, oh, meine
Augen, meine Augen, ich brauche, Moment, this is just pseudo code, ja count, wenn ich das
hier schon sehe, man, was zum Toll, da haben sie sich auch was ausgedacht, genauso eklig
wie Schleifen in Ansible, wobei es da mittlerweile Möglichkeiten gibt, dann guckt euch, guckt
euch das mal an, hallo, wie wäre es einfach mal mit einem Beispiel, eh, count, ja, ja,
das ist doch eklig, was habe ich da ausgedacht, man kann irgendwie Neo-Wim-Stream, oh, das
müssen wir auch noch machen, ja, nee, wahrscheinlich, also morgen gar nichts, also, wobei morgen
bin ich arbeiten und dann abends wahrscheinlich Kreiser grind, Wochenende muss ich ein Video
machen, da machen wir ein bisschen Kubernetes-Stells, mal gucken, wann wir das mit Neo-Wim machen,
mir ist eine Sache letztens aufgefallen, was an Ansible kacke ist, im Vergleich zu Puppet,
wir haben ja bei mir auf der Arbeit relativ viel Puppet noch, weil da seit, keine Ahnung,
aber 10 Jahren dran rumgewurstelt wird, da gab es noch kein Ansible und Puppet hat ein
schönes Feature, man kann sagen, also Server-Konfiguration, sowohl in Ansible als auch in Puppet kann
man z.B. definieren, dieser Server braucht den User Max mit Berechtigung auf Verzeichnis
xy und sowas, kann man in beiden Tools konfigurieren, ist kein Problem, aber in Puppet kann man
sagen, Puppet run no-op und dann zeigt er einem an, was er machen würde, das geht in Ansible
zwar theoretisch auch mit, glaub wie heißt das, Test-Mode, bei Ansible ist es aber so,
dass Test-Mode nicht so schön anzeigt, also was er jetzt genau machen würde und das Test-Mode
optional ist, also Test-Mode ist nichts, was Ansible direkt unterstützt, sondern was,
was die unterschiedlichen Provider und Module unterstützen müssen, also da muss ich sagen,
da finde ich das, wie es Puppet gemacht hat, immer noch schicker, dafür finde ich Ansible
viel einfacher zu handhaben als Puppet.
Frage als Informatiker, Zubi, ich würde gerne ein wenig mehr in die Welt von Linus einsteigen,
da hat er bisher nur wenig Berührungspunkt, da hast du gute Tipps für den Einstieg in
die Linus Welt.
Bei uns wird eigentlich nur Windows benutzt, tja gut, dann ist das natürlich ein bisschen
schwierig auf der Arbeit in Kontakt mit Linus zu kommen, wenn die nur Windows verwenden,
da bleibt dir nichts übrig für dich privat ein bisschen damit zu beschäftigen oder aber
vielleicht gibt es ja tatsächlich die Möglichkeit, dass du was auf der Arbeit machst, was irgendwie
auch für den Arbeitgeber von Mehrwert ist, fällt mir jetzt spontan ehrlich gesagt nichts
ein, man könnte ja Microsoft SQL auf Linus hosten, du willst lachen, also das funktioniert,
das ist sogar mittlerweile offiziell supported, aber ich wüsste nicht, warum man das machen
sollte, wenn man außerdem jetzt nicht mehr so an das Masochist sich veranlagt.
Du kannst dich natürlich privat damit beschäftigen, das ist kein Ding, installierst du dir eine
VM, installierst du ja VM oder Virtual Box oder sonst was und dann installierst du dir
neben deiner Linux Kiste, neben deiner Windows Kiste, installierst du dir eine Linux Kiste
oder eine VM und dann kannst du rumwurschteln, nee, nee, nee, kein Kubernetes Cluster installieren,
Leute empfehle den Leuten nicht so komische Dinge, er hat kein Linux Knowhow und die Leute
dort in der Firma haben auch kein Linux Knowhow, warum sollen die sich eine eigene Kubernetes
Cluster installieren?
Na gut, vielleicht ist das auch die Taktik, ihr wollt, dass die Firma pleite geht, weil
sie nur Windows verwendet sonst, nee, machst du dir hier eine VM, Linux drauf, gut ist,
ich lösche das mal und da kannst du hier ein bisschen mit rum basteln, du kannst dir
natürlich auch irgendwelche Cloud VMs mieten und sowas, wobei ich ehrlich gesagt sagen
würde, nimm nichts, was im Internet hängt, sondern probier es lokal aus und ich finde
ja persönlich, dass es die beste Variante, was du machen kannst, wenn du eine Linux,
nee, du kannst auch einen Raspberry Pi holen, aber Raspberry Pi sind aktuell zu teuer, also
ich finde es am sinnvollsten, du setzt dich erstmal ganz normal mit Linux auseinander
in Form von irgendeiner Installation in einer VM mit grafischem Interface und arbeitest
ein bisschen so mit Linux da, wo es halt geht, so mache ich das ja auch, ich habe hier meine
VM auf dem zweiten Desktop und ich mache alles, was nicht unbedingt unter Windows gemacht
werden muss in meiner Linux VM und da lernt man schon einiges dabei, einfach wenn du das
tagtäglich benutzt, du lernst was, wo man bestimmte Pakete konfiguriert, wie man Kommando
Zeilen Sachen händelt und sowas, das lernt man wahrscheinlich im täglichen Umgang als
Desktop Distribution, wo man halt drauf arbeitet und auch täglich benutzt, besser als sich
ab und zu mal per SSH auf dem Server einloggen und da ein bisschen rumbasteln, also das würde
ich machen, ganz ehrlich, ich würde gar nicht mit Server Anwendungen anfangen, auch wenn
das vielleicht dein Ziel ist in Zukunft, dass du sagst, hey du willst nochmal Linux Server
administrieren, aber du brauchst erstmal Linux Grundlagen und Linux Grundlagen heißt unter
anderem Kommando Zeilen lernen und generell so ein bisschen Linux Feeling und Kenntnisse
aufbauen und da ist tatsächlich das Beste, man verwende das tagtäglich, das heißt mach
dir ne Linux VM, hau dir ne Archlinux drauf und ne Ubuntu, ne ne Ubuntu oder so was zum
Mintlinux zum starten, wobei ich ja auch persönlich sagen würde, so ein Archlinux Install ist
auch kein Ding, weil wenn du es geschafft hast, dort ein grafisches Environment zu installieren,
sodass es ganz gut funktioniert, hast du schon mal einiges gelernt, wird aber am Anfang
vielleicht ein bisschen frustrierend, aber das ist wichtig, also wenn du täglich damit
arbeitest lernst du unglaublich viel, du lernst mehr als Kurse, ganz ehrlich Kurse bringen
überhaupt nichts, Kurse sind gut, um so die ganzen Begriffe, die mit dem Thema zu tun
haben aufzuschnappen, ich hab mir beispielsweise auch vor ein paar Wochen bei Udemy so im Schnelldurchgang
ein paar Kubernetes Sachen angeguckt und auf YouTube, damit ich da ein bisschen so ein bisschen
wieder, was die Basics angeht, besser durchblicke, ich hab das aber total schnell durchgeskippt
und hab mir angeguckt, ok, ok, ok, ich brauch im Hinterkopf, muss ich mir beispielsweise
merken, Helmcharts anpassen, eigenes Value-File, ok, Ingress-Controller, guck da, hier, da,
hab ich ganz schnell durchgemacht innerhalb von einem Tag, das war irgendwie ein Kurs
mit irgendwie 12 Stunden Videolaufzeit oder so was, ich hab die Videos auf 1,25% Geschwindigkeit
gestellt und hab noch die ganze Zeit hier File-Taste gedrückt nach vorne und dann hatte
ich so einen Chrom-Überblick und dafür sind Kurse gut, aber ansonsten zum tiefgreifend
lernen, musste die Kurse machen und gleichzeitig dabei üben oder am besten halt auch tagtäglich
verwenden, tagtäglich verwenden ist das Beste, was du machen kannst, ja Mail-Server, Mail-Server
ist auch nix, was man eigentlich machen will, Mail-Server ist total abartig, ja, also wirst
auf jeden Fall sehr viel lernen, wenn du dir ein Linux-System installierst in der VM und
das versuchst täglich so für die meisten Sachen, die nicht unbedingt Windows erfordert
oder sag mal so, muss ja auch nicht für das meiste machen, ja normales Internet surfen
auf YouTube und so, das mach ich hier noch in meiner Windows-Kiste, aber so für ein
bisschen, wenn du was programmierst, wenn du ein bisschen was basteln willst, dann mach
das unter Linux, ich würd sagen ich bin tagsüber so ungefähr so 60% unter Linux, ja ungefähr
60% unter Linux unterwegs, ungefähr 40% unter Windows unterwegs und da lernst du viel,
weil du wirst auf einmal Probleme haben, wo du dich fragst, hey wie konfigurier ich das
jetzt, da musst du gucken, wie du auf der Kommandozeile was editierst, gucken wo liegt
denn die Konfig-Datei und solche Geschichten, was denn das, und dann stellst du zum Beispiel
fest, fuck meine Tastatur ist kaputt und jetzt geht sie wieder nachdem man das Terminal neu
gestartet hat, alles gut, ja so würd ich das machen, ich finde Jason tatsächlich angenehmer
als Jaml, das stimmt, dass Jason keine Kommentare unterstützt, allerdings neuere Versionen
oder Standards von Jason können ja mittlerweile auch kommen, aber vieles unterstützt das
noch gar nicht, haben wir letztens erst, letztens erst uns angeguckt, also es könnte
auch irgendeine Extension gewesen sein, wo irgendeiner zum Standard was dazu gedichtet
hat, aber ich bilde mir ein, in einem der neueren Standards gibt es mittlerweile auch
Kommentare, meine Augen, aber das unterstützen noch nicht viele, ja das stimmt, na gut man
kann auch unter Pulumi irgendwie auch Terraform-Provider benutzen oder?
Das nervige an Terraform ist, dass man sich selbst um den State kümmern muss, naja irgendwo
musst du deinen State doch ablegen, das ist eh das beste, wenn du Terraform, also den
State würd ich nie in Skitrepo oder so einchecken, was zum Beispiel ganz cool sein muss, ist
wenn man, das kann ich aus praktischer Erfahrung nicht sagen, aber wenn ich jetzt nochmal was
neu machen würde mit Terraform und was vorschlagen könnte, dann würde ich sagen, dass man das
einfach in irgendeinen S3 Storage in der Cloud mit eincheckt, weil dann hast du das
auch, ok wie gesagt CDK hab ich schon nie verwendet, was ich Neo will machen, ich will
mir mal angucken, wie so das Plugin Ökosystem ist und wie man das gescheit mit Lua konfiguriert,
ich hab ja NeoWim noch nie, ich hatte das schon eine Weile mal installiert, ganz am
Anfang als das neu war, das war noch irgendwie 01 oder sowas, weil die da asynchrone Syntax
Highlighting und sowas drin hatten, was ich ganz cool fand, danach habe ich aber aufgehört
Wim aufzubohren, mega krass und bin hauptsächlich auf Wishl Studio Code und Jetbrain IDEs umgeschwenkt
für alles was ich so mache und benutze Wim jetzt tatsächlich nur noch für Dinger wie
Kommandozeilen editieren und dementsprechend kurz ist meine Wim RC auch, da ist nix mehr
großartig drinnen, ich weiß bei manchen Sachen auch gar nicht mehr warum die da überhaupt
drinnen stehen.
Übrigens, es gibt ein sehr cooles Projekt für AWS Entwickler, ich zeige euch das mal
falls ihr das noch nicht kennt, ich hab selbst noch nicht verwendet, aber ich bin letztens
darüber gestolpert, die haben fast alle AWS Apis nachgebaut, sodass man sie lokal verwenden
kann, das ist nicht für Performance oder so gedacht, das ist nur dafür gedacht, dass
man nicht schon während der Entwicklung 50.000 Euro Kosten verursacht laufend, also du kannst
mehr oder weniger alle AWS Apis lokal damit verwenden, ist auch nicht ganz unbeliebt mit
46.000 Stern, kannst das lokal hosten und dann ohne dass du Cloud Ressourcen brauchst lokal
dein Kram ausprobieren und dagegen entwickeln, das finde ich klingt sehr nice, nur dass
ich halt kein AWS verwende normalerweise, also keine Ahnung wie gut das wirklich ist, aber
die Idee dahinter finde ich nice, man kann auch so Sachen wie DynamoDB und sowas verwenden,
wie gesagt die API, das heißt nicht zwangsläufig, dass das wirklich auch performant ist wie
in der Cloud, das läuft ja immer in lokal und ist in Python implementiert, kann es ja
gar nicht sein, aber es ist viel angenehmer gegen was zu entwickeln was lokal ist, als
wo du laufend dann auch noch Geld dafür bezahlen musst, ja Bind macht auch kaum noch einer,
also Bind brauchst du an manchen Stellen, aber in der Regel brauchst du es nicht und
der Meldsober macht auch keiner mehr dabei, verstand es selbst, wir haben letztens zum
Beispiel ein bisschen Kubernetes Zeug gebaut, machen wir übrigens demnächst auch weiter,
es sind noch ein paar Sachen offen und ich habe mir dann mal so überlegt, ok, mal realistisch
betrachtet, ich hätte irgendeinen Managed Kubernetes Cluster in der Cloud, was würde
ich darauf laufen lassen und ich würde tatsächlich gucken, dass ich nach Möglichkeit, reine
Nachmöglichkeit sage ich ja, so gut wie nur stateless Anwendung drauf laufen lasse und
alles andere wo state irgendwie hin muss, über Cloud Services laufen lasse, wenn ich
es in der Cloud laufen lassen will, wohlgemerkt, also ich würde die Datenbank nicht selber
hausten im Kubernetes Cluster, ich würde irgendeine Managed Datenbank benutzen, ich
würde auch irgendwelche Message Queues und sowas nicht im Kubernetes hausten, sondern
irgendwelche Cloud Services dafür verwenden, weil man muss sich ja nicht, also wenn man
sich schon dafür entschieden hat, Sachen in der Cloud zu verwenden, dann muss man sich
ja auch nicht unnötig das Leben schwer machen, sondern kann das benutzen, was angeboten wird,
wenn es preislich hinhaut und alles kann, was man will, aber ich meine, was soll eine
Managed Postgres in der Google Cloud nicht können, das ist das stinknormale Postgres
der Datenbank, nur dass man sich nicht selbst um Failover, Cluster Management, Master Selection
und sowas, oh darf man das, ich weiß gar nicht ob das auch, ob das Wort überhaupt noch
ok ist, Master Selection kümmern muss und sowas, ist halt viel angenehmer.
Hast du was mit dem Wireless Wirecube, mit dem was, dem Wireless Wirecube, nee sagt mir
gar nichts, was ist der Wire, der Wireless Wirecube, das ist irgendein Outdoor Access
Point, auf 5G ist Out, jetzt sind wir bei 60G schon angelangt, keine Ahnung wofür man
den verwendet, nee, du benutzt auf der Arbeit auch eine vm, nee mache ich nicht, auf der
Arbeit habe ich Linux auf dem Notebook installiert, ich habe ein Windows Notebook und ein Linux
Notebook, da muss ich mal gucken, ob ich da meinen neuen Arbeitgeber auch dazu bringe,
mir zwei Notebooks zu geben, eins für Linux Installation und eins mit Windows, was man
für alle Firmen interne Geschichten braucht, ich könnte allerdings auch ohne Probleme
mit einer vm leben, ob ich rein mit WSL leben kann, weiß ich noch nicht, WSL, das ist immer
so ein Thema, wo alle sagen, ja es funktioniert doch alles und dann weißt du genau im Hinterkopf,
es gab immer mal gewisse Sachen, die nicht funktioniert haben in WSL, aber es fällt
dir dann immer nicht passend ein dazu, ich müsste eigentlich mal eine Liste machen mit
Dingern, die in WSL nicht ordentlich funktionieren, weil immer wenn es um die Frage geht, na was
ist es, warum geht es, warum nicht WSL, dann sage ich immer, weil nicht alles richtig funktioniert
in WSL und dann wollen sie immer wissen, ja wie, ich denke es funktioniert alles, was
denn genau und dann fällt mir das meistens nicht ein, aber es gibt Sachen, also Summer
Games zum Beispiel, funktionieren WSL 2 irgendwo oder WSL 1, keine Ahnung, nicht richtig, Port
Weiterleitung, ja es gibt noch mehr, grafische Anwendung ist auch so ein Ding, es gibt immer
wieder so Dinge, wo du Probleme hast mit WSL, man fährt, also wenn man so geil mit WSL fahren
würde, warum sollte ich ein Linux-VM verwenden, na gut, weil ich E3 mag, viel lieber als Windows,
und ich denke schon, dass man Leuten, die im Linux-Umfeld unterwegs sind, irgendeine
Linux-Umgebung zur Verfügung stellen muss, du musst auch mal ein paar, du musst auch
Tools ausprobieren können, du musst auch mal irgendeinen Package installieren können,
du brauchst auch mal, was weiß ich, sei es so, dass du irgendeinen Cube-CTL-Plugin installieren
willst oder sowas, was dann unter Windows manchmal eventuell Probleme macht, weil der
Virenscanner meint, oh nee, der lädt da was runter, das will ich nicht, das haben wir
zum Beispiel bei mir aktuell auf der Arbeit, wenn ich Log-Dateien kopiere unter WSL, jetzt
kein Witz Leute, müsst ihr euch mal reinziehen, wenn ich Log-Dateien kopiere per SCP über
WSL, dann bricht das nach irgendwie 25 MB ab und kriegt ganz komische IO-Read-Write-Errors,
warum?
Weil der Virenscanner meint, die Log-Datei oder mein SCP wäre irgendeine Ransomware,
die gerade Festplatten verschlüsselt und deswegen wird es abgebrochen.
Kann man über WSL einen Windows-Manager laufen lassen?
Theoretisch bestimmt praktisch ist es unsinnig, ich glaube nicht, dass es gescheit funktioniert,
man kann es vielleicht laufen lassen, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es gescheit
funktioniert.
Welche Distributionen ich auf der Arbeit benutze?
Also ich hatte ganz lang das hier auch auf der Arbeit, also ok, da war es noch mal Jaro,
da war es noch kein echtes Archlinux, by the way, ich benutze Archlinux, nur dass ihr
es wisst, muss man glaube ich immer mal wieder ein bisschen erwähnen, das erwarten die
Leute von einem, wenn man Archlinux benutzt, das ist ein bisschen so mit Veganer, die dir
erzählen, dass sie Veganer sind, man muss erwähnen, dass man Archlinux verwendet, by
the way.
So, also das war eine ganze Zeit lang Manjaro, hatte ich bei mir auch daheim und auf der
Arbeit und jetzt habe ich daheim in Archlinux kein Manjaro mehr und auf der Arbeit habe
ich tatsächlich Ubuntu, aber wisst ihr warum ich Ubuntu habe?
Einfacher Grund ist, ich hatte dort auch meine Manjaro Installation und ich musste das Notebook
wechseln und das war vor nicht all zu langer Zeit, da wusste ich schon, dass ich abhaue,
da habe ich mir gedacht, Leute ich mache jetzt keine extra Archinstallation auf meinem Notebook
und richte das schön ein, auch wenn es schnell geht mit meinen Dot Files aus dem Git Repo,
trotzdem dauert es ein bisschen länger als Ubuntu Installation, aber ich dachte, komm
für die drei Monate haust du dir dann noch ein Ubuntu drauf und gut ist, weil ich bin
auch total unmotiviert auf der Arbeit, muss ich ehrlich sagen, es ist nicht so, dass ich
gar nichts mache, aber seit ich gekündigt habe, bin ich extrem unmotiviert, mich interessiert
da auch nichts mehr großartig, ich freue mich wirklich drauf, wenn es beim neuen losgeht,
ich habe da überhaupt keinen Bock mehr drauf gerade, also wie gesagt, ich benutze keine
VM auf der Arbeit, ich habe ein Surface Book von Microsoft, Microsoft Surface Book, was
ich rein als statisches Notebook verwende, also ich verwende weder die Tablet Funktion
noch die Touch Funktion noch sonst was, es ist als zugeklapptes statisches Notebook mit
einem Monitor dran und einer USB Tastatur, also nichts spezielles, da ist Linux drauf
installiert und es läuft auch ganz gut auf dem Surface Book, Official Arch, ja, kein
Arch Flavor, sondern hier, Poggers, Pogu Arch, ja, das ist eine gute Idee, kann man
für forever die Free Variante benutzen oder ist die sehr trash, du meinst den Player,
der Player ist okay, du kannst aber auch Virtual Box verwenden oder du holst der für 3,50
Euro, kannst du dir bei einem Keyshop eine Forever Workstation Pro Lizenz holen oder
vielleicht auch aus anderen Quellen, aber da werde ich dir jetzt nichts schicken dazu,
ich habe mir die auch aus dem Keystore geholt für 7 Euro oder so damals und das reicht
voll und ganz aus, warum mehr ausgeben als nötig, sind die Keys für 10 Euro legit,
keine Ahnung, ist mir auch egal, ich habe die legit gekauft und sie haben legit funktioniert,
das ist eben eine Mario Playlist, Mario Sunshine, Sunshine Soundtrack, wie kann man nur auf
die Idee kommen, dass man in Jason keine Commons braucht, naja, weil das ursprünglich nicht
dafür gedacht war, Konfig-Dateien da drin zu erstellen oder irgendwie super menschenlesbar
zu sein, wobei man halt sagen muss, die Erweiterung, wisst ihr eigentlich, Chat, wisst ihr, wisst
ihr, dass Jammel quasi von Jason abstammt, auch wenn es nicht so aussieht, dass jedes
gültige Jason ein gültiges Jammel ist, sieht ganz anders aus, ist aber so, auch wenn es
komplett anders aussieht, du kannst jedes gültige Jason in der Jammel-Datei speichern
und es ist automatisch gültiges Jammel, ja, den kenne ich, den kenne ich, den kenne ich,
ich gehe davon aus, dass es nicht viele Leute benutzen, diesen Infinite Storage-Klitsch,
also ich zeige es euch mal für Leute, die es nicht gesehen haben bisher, da ist jemand
auf die, ach guck mal archiviert ist es, ok, warum, warum, warum ist es archiviert?
Wahrscheinlich weil es zu viele Issues gegeben hat oder, der Typ hat keinen Bock mehr, der
hat glaube ich keinen Bock mehr, der Dude, kann das sein, also du konntest dort Dateien
umwandeln in Videofiles, die dann so aussahen, quasi aus mehr oder weniger Rauschen bestanden
haben und die konntest du auf YouTube hochladen und YouTube hat ja keine Beschränkungen,
was Video-Uploads angeht und dann konntest du das quasi runterladen und dann wieder zurück
wandeln in die Datei, das ist nichts neues, dieses Verfahren an sich gibt es schon ganz
lange und es ist jetzt bloß bekannt geworden so die letzten paar Monate über, wahrscheinlich
weil Hacker-News oder Fortchain oder wer auch immer das Projekt entdeckt hat, es gibt viele
andere solcher Sachen auch schon länger, ich gehe davon aus, dass es kaum einer nutzt,
weil es nicht so, du könntest damit theoretisch Sicherheitskopien über YouTube verteilen,
natürlich nur für dich selbst, ich gehe davon aus, dass es nicht so viele Leute benutzen,
weil YouTube sonst einfach sperren würde, es ist auch nicht so sinn, es ist auch nicht
wirklich praktikabel gut zu benutzen, die Dateien, also die Videodateien sind eine ganze
Ecke größer als die Ursprungsdateien, das Uploaden dauert ewig, wenn es größere Dateien
sind, du musst ja vorher auch noch verschlüsseln und sowas, du kannst dann auch nicht gescheit
zippen, na gut, du kannst zuerst zippen und dann verschlüsseln, ja doch, das funktioniert,
dann den Videos umwandeln, die Dateien sind riesengroß, du brauchst lange zum Upload,
du brauchst ja vielleicht nicht ganz so lange zum Download, also jetzt so wirklich großartig
sinnvoll, finde ich es in der Handhabung nicht, natürlich, natürlich wäre es gut für Leute,
die irgendwelche Sachen sharen wollen, größere Sachen und das nicht über irgendwelche One-Click-Hoster,
Usenet oder sonst was machen würden, sobald das anfängt Fahrt aufzunehmen, wird folgendes
passieren, YouTube wird die Dinge einfach sperren, weil sowas kann YouTube ja easy erkennen,
ob ein Video so aussieht, das dürfte für YouTube gar kein Problem sein, so und eventuell
baut YouTube, auch wenn es solche Videos erkennt, einfach Fehler ein, sodass sie nicht mehr
packt werden können, also da glaube ich nicht, dass das irgendwie großartig YouTube aufmischen
wird, 3500 Zeilen Neo-Wim-Conf, ok, dann machst du das heute, so wie ich das früher gemacht
habe, ich habe mein Wim früher auch komplett aufgemotzt und alles im Wim gemacht, hatte
ich auch ewig lange, ich weiß nicht wie lange, aber ewig lange WimRC und Unterordner und
alles, das habe ich dann irgendwann weggeschmissen und bin zum Beispiel Studio Code und JetBrains
rüber.
Motto kenne ich nicht, wie gesagt ich verwende auch wenig AWS, das ist richtig, für dich
als Privatperson macht das überhaupt keinen Sinn, also Sachen in der Cloud zu verwenden,
solange du mit Free-Kontingent auskommst und zu Kleinigkeiten brauchst du es gut, aber
jetzt irgendwie eine Datenbank in der Cloud Hause macht für dich als Privatperson wenig
Sinn.
Wo es für dich Sinn machen könnte ist, wenn du einen Service im Internet anbieten willst,
ja also nicht von dir für dich oder für dich daheim irgendwas, sondern du hast irgendwas
programmiert, das willst du der Welt zur Verfügung stellen, dann kann es durchaus
sinnvoll sein das in der Cloud laufen zu lassen, wobei man sagen muss billiger, auch wenn die
ganzen Verkäufer was Cloud-Produkte angehen wahrscheinlich anders erzählen werden, weil
in der Cloud erzählen sie dir immer so nach dem Motto, Cloud ist auch riesen Kostenersparnis,
weil du bezahlst ja nur das was du auch wirklich verwendest, naja das stimmt so ohne weiteres
nichts, das kommt immer ganz drauf an was für einen Serviceman verwendet und was man
dort für Garantien haben will, was man dort für Zugriffszeiten haben will, da gibt es
ja ganz viele verschiedene Abstufungen oftmals, ja es ist nicht nur bei VMs in der Cloud wo
du unterschiedliche Performance Ausstattung, auch bei Storage zum Beispiel, bei Storage
gibt es in AWS glaube 3 oder 5 verschiedene Sachen, du kannst das irgendwie hot, ne es
gibt glaube ich allein von Cold Storage irgendwie oder Archivspeicher irgendwie 3 verschiedene
Stufen, das ist ganz wirr und da bezahlst du auch unterschiedlich viel und je nach dem
ist es dann auch unterschiedlich wo du was bezahlst, ja bei dem einen ist der Upload
billiger und der Download billiger aber dafür ist das pro Gigabyte teurer und bei dem anderen
ist es pro Gigabyte billiger aber das Abrufen ist extrem teuer und sowas, das ist Riesenwissen
Wissenschaft für sich und du kannst in der Cloud auch total easy einfach 1000 Euro ausgeben
wenn du nicht aufpasst, gab ja schon Leute die haben es geschafft Serverless Functions
zu bauen die sich dann selbst aufgerufen haben oder um 3 Ecken dann in irgendeine Schleife
hatten und dann sind sie ins Bett und morgens sind sie aufgewacht an 70.000 Euro Rechnung
auf ihrem Account, in der Vergangenheit haben sich die Cloud an Peter da tatsächlich relativ
kulant gezeigt wahrscheinlich weil sie wussten sie bekommen das Geld eh nie und haben gesagt
ja es ist ok pass auf dass du nicht wieder Scheiße baust aber es geht halt genauso also
ich finde das macht durchaus Sinn als in der Cloud zu hausen aber und das ist jetzt eigentlich
das, das ist eigentlich das was ich sagen wollte ja also wie gesagt ich finde da ist
nicht viel dran wenn dir irgendwelche Verkäufer da sagen ja aber in der Cloud ist viel große
Kostenersparnis das billigste wenn du ein Kleiner, das billigste nicht unbedingt für
dich als Entwickler das einfachste aber das billigste ist höchstwahrscheinlich also wenn
du einen Service hast den du im Internet anbieten willst und du auch gar nicht weißt ob das
viele Leute benutzen miete dir eine Linux VM miete dir irgendwo bei Hetzner zum Beispiel
miete dir irgendeine billige Linux VM klatscht da deine Anwendung drauf und guck erstmal
wie es ankommt da kannst du zwar nichts von dem machen was dir die ganzen Cloud Leute erzählen
dass das super essenziell wäre du kannst das nicht rolling skalieren und du kannst
das nicht irgendwie großartig upgraden ohne dass du es runterfahren musst und solche
sonstige Geschichten und du kannst das auch nicht per Edge Computing und Edge Dingsbums
Distribution und haste nicht gesehen ausliefern aber das meiste kann man ja immer noch später
machen wenn man einfach nur was kleines programmiert hat gucken will wie das ankommt das billigste
und einfachste ist eine Linux VM bei irgendeinem Hoster das Ding draufgeschmissen am besten
noch mit irgendeiner SQLite Datenbank anstatt irgendwelche großen Datenbank Service sich
zu kaufen oder kannst ja auch darauf irgendeine Postgres installieren aber meistens reicht
für sowas kleines ja sogar SQLite aus wenn es komplett lokal auf der gleichen Kiste ist
und fertig muss man gar nichts großartig machen finde ich persönlich am sinnvollsten wenn
man es einfach nur ausprobieren will und sollte man wirklich den super mega Service erfunden
haben wo auf einmal letztendlich die Leute drauf stürzen ja gut die Chancen sind gering
wenn man für diese kleine Chance vorsorgen will muss man halt Geld in die Hand nehmen
und es von Anfang an so bauen dass man es irgendwie ordentlich ausrollen könnte in
der Cloud Umgebung wo es ordentlich skaliert aber eher nicht zumal man vieles ja auch auf
die schnelle machen kann du kannst ja erstmal deine VM also mehr aufrüsten also man kann
ja erstmal die einfachen Sachen machen ja ohne das komplett auf cloud native mit allen
cloud services und nur noch im managed Kubernetes Cluster und hast du nicht gesehen alles laufen
zu lassen also man kann ja auch erstmal seine VMs upgraden also sollte wirklich der Fall
eintreten dass man als Einzelentwickler ein Projekt gebaut hat das hostet der Welt zur
Verfügung stellt und auf einmal springen tausende Leute drauf und du hast auf einmal du hast
quasi über Nacht irgendwie hunderte oder tausende User und es geht ab weil zufälligerweise
PewDiePie ein Video über deinen Service gemacht hat ja gut dann kannst du erstmal einfach
deine VM erweitern da gibt es deine VM, RAM, CPU und das ist dann erstmal kommst du damit
ja auch relativ weit und dann musst du dir halt überlegen ok ich habe auf einen Schlag
500 Benutzer jetzt muss ich mir tatsächlich ein bisschen Mühe geben mit dem Service wobei
du halt weißt es ja noch nicht mal irgendwie ein Abo-Modell oder irgendwas hast wenn du
einfach als Privatperson was gebaut hast gucken willst wie es ankommt da hast du ja noch nicht
mal irgendwie Monetarisierungs Schema dir ausgedacht das ist ja meistens dann kostenloser
Webservice und da kann sich dann eh keiner beschweren also du hast sehe ich prinzipiell
auch so ich finde das meistens ist es für private Personen so für so Ein-Mann-Projekte
nicht sonderlich sinnvoll.
Kommt drauf an was man macht ja also ich habe gehört dass wir mittlerweile 6-stellig
im Monat ausgeben für die Cloud bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber also es ist nicht ohne
was da Geld raus reingebuttert wird aber wenn du das brauchst was die anbieten dann kann
sich das durchaus lohnen es hat ja seinen Grund dass die Cloud-Anbieter erfolgreich
sind und dass auch immer mal wieder neue auftauchen die manche Sachen besonders gut machen oder
einfacher machen oder fokussierter sind auf spezielle Bereiche als die großen ich meine
klar Google, Microsoft und Amazon die können irgendwie alles dafür sind sie unglaublich
komplex groß kompliziert und keiner blickt so wirklich durch am Anfang und ich glaube
es gibt ganz wenige die wirklich insgesamt durchblicken dann gibt es dann irgendwelche
Service so was wie Fly.io was jetzt gerade voll angesagt ist was spezielle Sachen einfacher
macht und dementsprechend auch für viele erstmal einfacher zu verstehen ist.
Linode habe ich noch nie verwendet habe ich aber schon öfters mal als guten Tipp gehört
für Managed Kubernetes und Managed in Anführungsstrichen viel Managed ist ja da nicht bei und Digital
Ocean Kubernetes soll auch nicht schlecht sein ansonsten wie die VMs von Linode sind
habe ich auch nicht schlechtes bisher gehört Managed ist bei diesen ganzen Sachen ja nicht
wirklich viel sondern eigentlich nur die wie heißt das bei Kubernetes die API also das
eigentliche Kubernetes die Control Plane heißt das genau also das ist ja meistens
bei der Kubernetes Service selber Managed also du kannst dann zum Beispiel darüber
abgehen dass die gucken dann halt dass Versions Upgrades durchgeführt werden in irgendeinem
Maintenance Winner was du eingetragen hast dass du dich nicht selbst machen musst und
solche Geschichten aber um alles andere in deinem Cluster auch wenn es ein Managed Cluster
ist musst du dich bei den meisten Anbietern dort eh selber kümmern da haben die größten
Anbieter was was cooleres Google hat zum Beispiel sowas wie ihren Kubernetes Autopilot da kriegst
du gar kein Kubernetes Cluster mehr im klassischen Sinne sondern du kriegst ein Kubernetes Cluster
wo du per Pod bezahlst oder nee nicht per Pod per doch per ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
du es per Pod bezahlst oder ob du es per Pod Typ bezahlst aber wahrscheinlich wirst du
es nach Pod bezahlen und dann halt je nachdem wie viele Replikas und sonst was man haben
will dafür musst du dich halt Null mehr drum kümmern um Kubernetes an sich ist da nochmal
so ein Zwischenschritt zwischen alles Serverless Functions oder Kubernetes Cluster so ein Zwischending
was ist das für Betge Musik ja
das habe ich gesehen das habe ich gesehen ich glaube nicht dass das das ziehen wird
wenn ich das sage
ob und Unity gibt es doch gar nicht mehr oder das ist doch jetzt alles auch genommen
welchen Keystore benutzt du so für Corporate Care meinst du Keystore oder Secret Store
also meinst du Keyvalue Geschichten oder wirklich Secret Store Secret Store Azure Key Vault
ganz einfach weil Azure und so Zeug weil wir Azure verwenden und da bietet sich das
an Azure Key Vault und ansonsten Redis das dürfte auch mit das verbreiteste sein was
so so Caching und solche Geschichten angeht
Jaml kompiliert ja unter der Haube zu Jason oder nicht das weiß ich nicht es gibt allerdings
Sachen Konstrukte in Jaml die kannst du in Jason so nicht machen zum Beispiel Referenzen
und sowas aber klar wenn das irgendwie dann zu Jason kompiliert dann glaube ich nicht
passt eigentlich nicht
Jason Jaml ist keine Alternativ Syntax für Jason also nicht jedes Jaml ist Jason aber
jedes Jason ist Jaml
ich benutze das Main Ubuntu ja das ganz das ganz stinknormale Ubuntu benutze ich was du
kriegst wenn du sagst hier Download Ubuntu verschicken die eigentlich noch kostenlos
CDs früher haben noch CDs verschickt das was du hier kriegst hier 22 04 LTS wir sind
übrigens sehe ich gerade wir sind bald bei Ubuntu 22 23 04 wie wird denn das heißen
Luna Lobster endlich mal wieder ein guter Ubuntu Name die letzten waren irgendwie nicht
so geil die letzten fand ich nicht so geil aber Luna Lobster ist Poggers ja so das war
cool das war cool war sich es war zu zweien den kann ich mich auch noch erinnern das ist
glaube ich den Namen den ich am meisten noch im Kopf habe was Ubuntu angeht ja die kenne
ich alle noch aber die war jetzt auch nicht so geil haben die nicht einfach mal eine Tabelle
wo man das sieht so eklig sowieso aber die letzten die letzten muss ich sagen die fand
ich jetzt gar nicht mehr so gar nicht mehr so toll Kinect Kudus Zungenbrecher das spricht
doch keiner so aus Luna Lobster ist mal wieder was was gut von der Zunge geht das fand ich
noch Kimchi Fisch oder Dragx
Coming?-like-smart-faces-letter- attractionen-b redistribution das wusste ich aber gar nicht
dass es existiert wenn ich eeherlich bin ist mir komplett neuer hab ich bis jetzt noch
aber ganz ehrlich
das Luna Lobster ist mal wieder was gutes
sind das die gleichen wie bei Debian? Nee
Debian hat Toy Story Namen
Debian benennt ihre Dinger immer nach Toy Story Characters
Ubuntu macht da irgendwelche komischen
wie nennt man das
diese Konstellation von Wörtern bei Ubuntu wie nennt man das
also Luna Lobster ist ja quasi das ist
nen, nen, nen
Tier ist mit L, nen Wort mit L am Anfang
was
halt irgendwie
ne Eigenschaft dann von dem Tier ist
Adjektiv und Tier
Adjektiv und Tier, ja genau
aber es muss aber es muss immer
das gleiche Adjektiv sein vom Anfang, also das gleiche Anfangsbuchstabe Adjektiv wie
im Tiername
bei Ubuntu
was?
ihr wechselt auch wieder
zurück
von der Cloud
aha
das leucht, vielleicht verstehe ich jetzt den Zusammenhang irgendwie nicht
was hat der Rails Erfinder und Google damit zu tun, das
ja gut
keine Ahnung
Brezelsnacker, danke für den Sub
sorry Leute, was ich heute wieder die Hälfte überlesen habe wahrscheinlich
warte mal, Chico
was ist da los?
so
Chico kratzt an der Tür rum
ja und der hat es archiviert aber warum weiß man nicht
oder weiß man das?
wie ist der Typ? Github
infinite
storage glitch
also ich meine der Source Code ist noch da
rework
update readme, ok was hat er da reingeschrieben, warum hat er das
gelöscht
oh ich glaube Youtube hat ihn angeschrieben, könnte das sein?
ah
so
ja das ist
die Leute erzählen im Internet viel wenn der Tag lang ist
kostenlose Ubuntu CDs gibt es schon lange nicht mehr
tja
es sagt
Moment es gibt ein Ubuntu Remix mit dem alten Unity aber warum das denn?
das fand ich ja noch schlimmer als den Gnome Desktop von denen
Leute falls ihr irgendwelche Fragen übersehen habt schreibt es ruhig in den Chat rein
ich hab wieder die Hälfte jetzt gerade überscrollt wahrscheinlich
Ed Wubblos davor
ich bin unten im Chat
ich hab noch im Hinterkopf gehabt, irgendwas wollte ich noch
beantworten aber
weiß nicht mehr was
ach stimmt
Unity wird ja von diesem 13 jährigen Typ weiterentwickelt ja
ja haben wir sogar letztens gesehen
Moment der hatte doch noch mehr oder?
der hat nicht nur an Unity entwickelt, der hatte doch auch irgendwelche anderen
Projekte
wo wir uns gedacht haben es ist irgendein Zwölfjähriger oder so
der das programmiert
ich hab gar kein Laufwerk mehr im Rechner drinnen
meine letzten paar Rechner hatten alle schon kein Laufwerk mehr
es haben ein paar Leute gefragt wann ich jetzt letzten Arbeitstag und ersten
Arbeitstag hab also
dazu gibt es ein Update
ich hab euch ja mal erzählt, mein letzter Arbeitstag ist spätestens der 22.
und je nach Hofbereitschaftskonto vielleicht schon der 17.
und mein erster Arbeitstag ist der 1.
beziehungsweise der
ja 3. oder 4. je nachdem um den Monat
wahrscheinlich gehe ich gleich Anfang der Woche hin
der 3. April ist mein erster
Arbeitstag aber es hat sich jetzt was anderes ergeben ich hab nämlich
folgendes entdeckt und zwar
wenn man innerhalb eines Jahres den Arbeitgeber wechselt kann man seine
Urlaubstage mitnehmen
wenn man eine Bescheinigung bekommt, also wenn der alte und der neue
Arbeitgeber damit einverstanden sind
und wenn man eine Bescheinigung bekommt vom alten Arbeitgeber
wie viele Urlaubstage
man schon
verbraucht hat dieses Jahr
sodass man halt nicht sagen kann hey
ich nehme die mit
aber ich will sie auch ausbezahlt haben ne Woche später oder sowas ja das wäre
dann beschiss
so mein neuer Arbeitgeber erlaubt das anscheinend, weil die haben sogar ne
Möglichkeit das Formular das hochzuladen
jetzt muss ich mal bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber fragen ob das ok ist
ich denke nicht dass die was dagegen haben die freuen sich wahrscheinlich
sogar wenn ich noch ne Woche länger da bin
bezahlen müssen sie es ja eh
und dann wäre mein letzter Arbeitstag tatsächlich erst
wahrscheinlich der neunundzwanzigste
was mir persönlich auch ganz lieb ist weil
ich habe überhaupt kein Interesse den sechs Tage Urlaub jetzt zu nehmen
ich will ich will überhaupt kein Urlaub nehmen ich will lieber wieder Urlaub
ordentlich am Stück nehmen
und nicht irgendwie so sechs Tage so im im im März total bescheuert hab ich
will ich überhaupt nicht
deswegen werde ich das mal checken
ob das geht
ich will jetzt überhaupt kein Urlaub machen
ist Fulltime Office Homeoffice bei dem neuen nee es ist nicht Fulltime Homeoffice
es ist
einmal die Woche
bis zu 14 Tage also einmal die Woche oder einmal alle 14 Tage
Office
je nach Absprache mit seinem Chef ich denke mal am Anfang
werde ich da schon einmal die Woche hingehen
allein schon dass man ein bisschen so die Leute mal gesehen hat
und dann
mal gucken ob man das ein bisschen ausweitet
da wird sich nichts mehr großartig tun die Übergabe ist abgeschlossen
gibt eigentlich nichts mehr was ich übergeben muss
nur ich muss mich vielleicht selbst übergeben wenn ich sehe wie bescheuert
sie das wieder gemacht haben
die haben einen Kerl dahin gesetzt
der
die Sachen von mir alle übernehmen soll
der die Sachen von meinem
Kollege
übernehmen soll der mit auch mit mir wechselt teilweise zumindest
dann macht er noch die Sachen weiter die er vorher gemacht hat
plus dass er sich jetzt noch mit unserem Mailsystem auseinandersetzen soll
wie soll das funktionieren
und das beste ist das beste ist
das ist ein externer Mitarbeiter der nur einen Vertrag für ein halbes Jahr hat
der ist dann weg und auf einmal haben die gar keinen Plan mehr was abgeht
also da schaufen sie sich gerade wirklich ihr Grab
der der haut einfach ab wenn er keinen Bock mehr hat aber vollkommen vollkommen zurecht
also keine Ahnung was sie sich dabei wieder gedacht haben
ja morgen habe ich auch mal einen Termin mit meinem Chef da werde ich das mal
werde ich das klären wie das mit dem mit dem Urlaub mit dem Urlaub nehmen ist
und und was mein Abschlusszeugnis macht
Abschlusszeugnis müssen sie nämlich auch endlich mal hinkriegen
ich habe das ich habe das alles ausgefüllt mein Chef hat es auch
ausgefüllt und irgendwie hört man dann nichts mehr von
die sind total lahm was das angeht und ich brauche das Abschlusszeugnis
also was ich brauche
nicht wirklich aber ich will eins haben
wie wo ist das wo ist das Problem viele Emoils zu benutzen
das kann ich überhaupt nicht verstehen ist nicht ist nicht Emoils eigentlich das
beste an ganz twitch beste einfach nur den ganzen tag Emoils spam
ich habe auch keine Probleme wenn der Chat Emoil Only ist wobei das mag ich
nicht eigentlich mag ich mag ich Emoil Only Chats nicht
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein nein wieder ausmachen
ja was machen aber Emoils sind doch echt das beste eigentlich so das mal kurz
gucken wir jetzt wie wir klotz noch immer irgendwas auf wir gucken uns noch mal
irgendwas auf auf youtube an gibt es da irgendwelche spannen
the brutal downfall of better twitch tv 1 extension that millions of ok lass mal so
auf was haben wir denn zu was haben wir denn zur Auswahl zu gucken
ffm pack in 100 sekunden ok war feier schipp kommen wir gucken feier schipp
ffm pack ist tatsächlich beste also ich glaube ich könnte ich könnte keine
videos ohne ffm pack mehr erstellen in open source command line ffm pack in
open source command line tool for processing audio and video files it was
created by fabrice billard in the year 2000 the name stands for fast forward
followed by the moving picture experts group file format today it's used in a
wide variety of tools dafür steht das ok ich wusste bis jetzt nicht ffm pack
steht was like google chrome and blender und das logo ist auch kacke
well it's video platforms like youtube in vimeo it's able to decode encode
transcode multiplex demultiplex stream filter and play virtually any
multimedia file in the world with over 100 different codecs supported it works
by taking an input file then passes it to a demultiplexer that splits the audio
and video tracks into separate encoded data packets these packets are then
decoded into uncompressed frames which can be further processed and filtered you
might modify the brightness and contrast add subtitles or visualize the audio as a
das das beste das beste an ffm pack ist ja dass das um encoden von einem format
ins andere format das ist das wo es wahrscheinlich auch mit abstand die
meisten leute benutzen halt im endeffekt zum video rendern
damals gerade windows build speed oder verwende ich ja wahrscheinlich sachen
von einem arbeitskollege dann feinlich die frames aren't code weil ich hab
natürlich auch ffm pack installiert und multiplexed back into the output file in
addition it also comes with the ff play tool to easily play media from the
command line and ff probe to extract metadata from a file in addition to tons
of low-level libraries for developers building their own multimedia processing
ffm pack kann fast alles einzige was ffm pack nicht kann was mich ein bisschen
stört ist wie heißt dieses komische nachfolge format was ich google ausgedacht
hat für png web web nein nein web p ja genau das kann ffm pack nicht und ich
verstehe nicht warum
oder nie animiertes werb p kann es nicht animiertes werb p kann es nicht
irgendwie so gab's da gab's da probleme ich merke das merkt das immer wieder weil
ich zum beispiel suche nach betta twitch tv keck weh oder oder keine ahnung wenn
ich irgendwelche animierten emote suche sind die manchmal in webp animation
formaten das kriegt ffm pack nicht hin benutzt du dein selbst made pop shots
noch ja den habe ich immer noch dran hier guckt das ist immer noch mein schwamm
den ich am mikrofon stecken habe
hänne das funktioniert nicht guck mal ffz nehmen wir mal gatschi roll so
oder sowas hier so wenn ich das runter lade ist das ja web web p also keckel so
achtung achtung downloads ff play
im ist data not found
es geht nicht könnte das sein dass einfach diese dass es nicht alles kann
von web p also der browser kanns aber ffm pack kann es nicht image data not
found das habe ich jetzt schon paar mal gemerkt
dass ffm pack mit dem format probleme hat
ach guck mal das kann die encode aber nicht die kauten
moment die können bilder erstellen aber bilder nicht einlesen
na gut wie gesagt das weiß ich dass das dass es damit probleme hat
ansonsten ist ffm pack das beste
to get started install it then open up the terminal use the ffm peg command
followed by I to supply one or more input files to convert that file to a
different format simply provide the name of the output it will was ffm pack
minus e image 2 ok geht das geht das auch bei bei ff play
nee ok ff ffm pack probieren jetzt mal aus
minus e was image 2 warum image 2 ok image 2 aber aber das im moment minus e
geht auch gar nicht minus e ist das input feil chat was ihr über zeug
schreibt es gibt überhaupt keinen sinn will automatically detect the file
extension and convert it to the proper codec or the c-flag can be used to
specify an explicit codec like mpeg 4 for the video track and mp3 for the audio
minus f image 2 ok ok ff play minus f image 2 ok geht das bei ff play vielleicht
image no data found
oder oder muss man das f nach minus i machen
nee nee nee keine chance ja
Das ist vor sieben Jahren, okay?
Ne, das JPG kann FFmpeg ja auch, weil es den Encoder hat und es hat keinen Decoder hierfür.
Gibt's nicht, deswegen geht das auch nicht. Ja, benutzt kaum einer. Aber du kannst extrem,
hier kannst du übrigens auch Sachen skippen und so was. Du kannst ja auch mit FFmpeg Videos
schneiden auf der Kommandozeile, wenn man will. Und es gibt minus S ist skip am Keyframe und
minus SS ist skip exakt zum Timestamp oder so. Bin mir gerade im Kopf nicht ganz sicher. Gibt
2, gibt 2, gibt minus SS und minus S als Kommentar, als nicht als Kommentar, als Option. Ich skaliere
damit übrigens seit einer Weile meine Videos hoch, weil ich nehme ja selbst so ein 1080p auf,
aber die Bandbreite in 1080p auf YouTube ist einfach Müll, deswegen skaliere ich die einfach
hoch auf 1440p und dann sehen sie auf einmal viel besser aus.
Ich will ja FFmpeg verwenden Leute, dass es jetzt irgendein anderes Tool gibt, was das kann. Gehe
ich jetzt mal von aus. Ich meine ImageMagic, habe ich überhaupt ImageMagic installiert? Kann
das, kann das wahrscheinlich auch, ja. Image, Image to WebP? Was zum, was ist das? Ok. Convert.
Ne, wie heißt das Programm zum Anzeigen bei ImageMagic? Boah, keine Ahnung. Egal, ich
deinstalliere es jetzt wieder. Braume erinnert, ImageMagic ist Legacy Zeug. Westfirm? Ne,
das glaube ich nicht. Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal. Ich würde sagen, kann es nicht.
Hat, aber, hey, ich meine, es geht auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung, aber hat von
so ein bisschen noch Probleme damit. Also kann es, kann es auch nicht richtig. Wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich kann es statische Images und nicht animierte Images. Ja. Ne, ne, ne, keine
Chance, das kann es nicht. Hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert. Ja, lass mal kurz YouTube
reloaden, ob da noch irgendwas spannendes dabei, dabei ist. Was, building a rack-mounted
Proxmox-Server? Ja, soll er machen. Müssen wir uns jetzt aber nicht angucken, das ist
sehr unspektakulär. Haben wir noch irgendwas? Wir haben noch, wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde
Zeit. Komm, irgendwas, irgendwas spannendes gibt es doch noch. Linux Fundamentals, Fundamentals,
Ach du Scheiße, was ist das Wort? Fundamentals, oder? The Metaverse is dead. Okay. Hä, ist
das wirklich so? Mark Zuckerberg hat entschieden, das Metaverse zu töten. Es gab keine großen
Announcements und no funeral. Ist, ist das so? Ich mein, der übertreibt, er hat übertreibts
auch manchmal ganz schön mit seinem Zeug was er da erzählt, ja. Was ganz davon abgesehen,
dass das irgendjemand irgendwann, irgendwann wieder, irgendwann abhebt, wie sie sich das
erhofft haben, habe ich eh schwarz gesehen, aber nur weil ich das, weil ich das nicht
sehe. Hey guck mal, die Leute haben jetzt auf einmal Füße. Ich dachte, der Metaverse
hat halt keine mehr Beine und Füße. Und wie kommt er da jetzt drauf? Okay, wir gucken
mal kurz News. Es stimmt überhaupt nicht. Okay, es gibt keine weiteren News dazu. Alles
klar, gut, nice, GG. Alles klar. Ja, der übertreibt manchmal so ein bisschen. So, also gucken
wir uns mal das an. The brutal downfall of BetterTwitchTV. Verwendet noch jemand BetterTwitchTV
von euch Leute? Ich verwende nur noch FFZ und nachdem FFZ auch BetterTwitchTV Emotes
kann und 7TV Emotes kann, macht es eigentlich gar keinen Sinn für mich mehr. Idee für
altes Notebook als Server, sowas wie Proxmox drauf oder was anderes, das kommt drauf an.
Leute, es macht keinen Sinn, irgendeine alte Kiste hinzustellen und daraus einen Virtualisierungshost
zu machen, wenn man nichts hat, was man virtualisieren will. Oder hast du was, was du virtualisieren
willst? Weil dann hast du es dir quasi schon selbst beantwortet, dass es Sinn macht, wenn
dir die Leistung ausreicht und wenn deine CPU das kann. Ansonsten sind alte Notebooks da
ganz gut für. Ich meine, die sind meistens recht leise, die brauchen nicht viel Strom
und die haben je nach Notebook auch ganz okay Leistung. Kann man verwenden für sowas? Habt
ihr eine Idee, wie ich einen Terminal UI Dialog, der sehr wahrscheinlich mit Dialog erstellt
wurde in einem Skript? Dialog ist das Ding mit diesem blauen Hintergrund und den, den
grafischen Dingern zum auswählen dann. Ich hab vergessen, wie das heißt. Wie nennt sich
das denn? Das hat so einen speziellen Namen, diese Art von dir. Ich zeig's euch mal. Weißt
du, Kekkel, wie benutzt man das? N-Curses, das meine ich, genau. Ach du Kacke. Wie macht
man das? Wie benutzt man das überhaupt? Wie, wie, wie, wie benutzt man? Der Thomas Dick
hat das, hat das programmiert, so, so. Wie, wie, wie, wie macht man das? Ich hab keine
Ahnung, wie man das überhaupt benutzt. Kalender? Was? Form? What? Gibt es nicht einfach Textbox?
Ok, Textbox. Textbox, ne, ne, gibt's nicht. Textbox? Null. Was? Leute, ich bin unfähig,
das zu benutzen. Ich, ich, so, ok, wie geht das? Zeig mal ein Beispiel. Dialog. Off.
Ja. Beispiel please. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ja und wie geht's? Yes, no, möchten
sie abrechen? Ok, alles klar, das will ich haben. Genau. So, das willst du automatisieren?
Ähm, das ist doch einfach.
Du willst xdo, xxdo-tool haben, da kannst du an Fenster Tasten-Inputs senden.
Und du willst dann den Tasten-Input senden, einmal Pfeiltaste rechts und Enter.
Kannste machen, Keypresses, das weiß ich aber aus dem Kopf gerade nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal, wie das funktioniert hier.
Press Key N, genau, ok, also machst du hier, Press Key N und Enter, ok, mach den Dialog
auf, oh, Key N und jetzt müssen wir das noch ans richtige Fenster, Fenster muss ja so
sein.
Groß N, ja, wir müssen es irgendwie im gleichen Fenster ausführen, das wird jetzt ein bisschen
eklig von der Sonntags her.
So, können wir das so machen, nein, ok, das hat nicht funktioniert, also es wird aber
funktionieren, wenn man es im zweiten Fenster macht, so und jetzt musst du halt hier angeben
an welches Fenster du das senden willst, das weiß ich aber aus dem Kopf ehrlich gesagt
nicht, wie das funktioniert, das musst du nachgucken.
To Specific Window, ja, ja, klar, da kannst du einstellen, an welches Fenster du deine
Tastendrücke, Tastendrücke schicken willst.
Es gibt theoretisch die Möglichkeit das Ganze auch noch in Expect oder so zu rappen, aber
das funktioniert glaube ich für grafische Tools nicht, beziehungsweise auch für grafische
Commandos, also Konsolentools nicht, da wirst du wahrscheinlich Tasten Inputs senden müssen.
Ja, Sarix, das kenne ich schon, das habe ich letztens, das habe ich letztens auch schon
gezeigt, ja, das ist eklig zu automatisieren, aber da wird ja nichts anderes übrig bleiben,
wie sowas zu machen hier, Sende, Sende Key, hier Sende Key, yes, hat doch funktioniert,
hat doch funktioniert, ja, Sleep, 2, guck, geht doch, ja, Error Right, wie macht man das,
Key Up, Down, Right, ok, also kann man auch sagen quasi, Right und Enter oder so, ja,
hat auch funktioniert, guck, er ist nach rechts, er ist nach rechts geswitcht und macht
Enter, ja, kannst du, kannst du, geht, ja, Zack, Bam, Switch, rechts, Enter, ja, kann
man auch sagen, so, so, so funktioniert das nicht, ja, ok, also, das funktioniert so nicht,
wie ich mir das gedacht habe mit dem Sleep, aber das kannst du so automatisieren, ja,
Simikolon vergessen, ne, ich wollte es hier dazwischen einbauen und ich dachte, das geht
vielleicht, dass man das direkt da Inline, Inline einbauen kann, weil ansonsten müsste
ich jetzt ja so machen, Sleep, 1, ne, und dann noch mal und dann Enter und so, das ist
natürlich auch doof, so, jetzt switcht er rüber, macht ein Sleep und drückt Enter,
ich würde auch jede Menge Sleeps einbauen an deiner Stelle, weil ansonsten ist das Shellscript
vielleicht nicht schnell genug.
Ja, wenn das geht, wenn das geht, ist natürlich sinniger, aber wenn du wirklich was automatisieren
willst, willst in der Kommandozeile mit Tasten drücken, dann bleibt dir ja nur sowas.
Ist eine Stelle als Junior Kubernetes Admin, ja, fragt die mal, wie sie Kubernetes aussprechen,
ist es Kubernetes, ist es Kubernetes, ist es Kubernetes oder sowas und wenn die sagen
Kubernetes, dann sagst du gleich, ne, zu euch will ich nicht, ne, keine Ahnung, was ich
dir als Junior Admin im Vorstellungsgespräch raten soll, ähm, außer das, was man immer
raten kann, nicht so wirklich jetzt aber spezifisch zu Kubernetes, ja, das würde ich nicht, das
sind aber so allgemeine Themen, ich überleg gerade, was man explizit für die Stelle als
Junior Kubernetes Admin sagen könnte.
Kommt halt drauf an, bei wem du das Vorstellungsgespräch hast, hast du das bei irgendeinem der Ahnung
hat oder ist das nur so ein erstes Scan-Gespräch von irgendeinem Typ von der Recruiting-Firma
oder von irgendeinem Personaler, der eh keinen Plan davon hat?
Also ist da jemand, vielleicht weißt du das, also dort, wo ich jetzt Vorstellungsgespräche
hatte, stand immer dabei, wer teilnimmt am Vorstellungsgespräch, ich hatte aber in letzter
Zeit nur zwei und eins war direkt mit dem Chef, also, äh, oder mit dem, ist ja nicht
Chef, es ist ja der, was ist der Technik-Chef mit dem CTO, wobei das halt auch eine kleinere,
größere Firma war, also da wusste ich halt mit wem ich rede und bei den anderen stand
es immer dabei, es nehmen teil, bla bla bla, Teamleiter-Bereiche, Exkursion, bla bla bla,
Personalabteilung.
Ein paar aus dem Team, alter, was wolle ich da irgendwie, die mangelte eben oder so, ich
finde es immer schon ein bisschen cringe, wenn da einem drei Leute gegenüber sitzen
und man denkt so, ja, alter, was wolle ich da da hinsetzen, acht oder was, ja, also, mir
fällt jetzt ehrlich gesagt, so Kubernetes-Admin-spezifisches jetzt nix so direkt ein, was man da vielleicht
mit was man punkten könnte, ich mein, du wirst ja schon ein bisschen Erfahrung haben als
Kubernetes, ich mein, es ist zwar eine Junior-Stelle, aber es ist eine Junior-Stelle, als Kubernetes-Admin,
aber es wird wahrscheinlich Anforderungen sein, dass man zumindest ein bisschen Plan
von Kubernetes hat.
Meinung zu Fefe, ich hab schon ewig Jahre nix mehr von Fefe gelesen, keine Ahnung was
der aktuell treibt.
Ja, natürlich kannst du ein bisschen von deinen Erfahrungen berichten, was du schon
gemacht hast.
Und ansonsten nur das allgemeine Zeug fällt mir jetzt gerade so spontan nichts ein.
Du versuchst Checkmk-Updates zu automatisieren und bei OMD, das ist das Kommando-Zeilen-Tool
von Checkmk, oder?
Dover Dialog, tja, sackt.
Bester Tipp, Leute, kein Scheiß machen.
Ich glaube, diesen Tipp kannst du auf 99% der Lebenssituationen anwenden.
Just, just kein Scheiß machen.
Das geht immer.
Und wenn's nicht läuft, dann hast du wahrscheinlich zu viel Scheiß gemacht.
Oh Leute, ich hab gerade eine Nachricht von Twitch bekommen.
Das Werbeprogramm von Twitch wird noch flexibler im April.
Ist mir egal, ich hab, glaub ich, noch nicht einmal Werbung laufen lassen in meinem Stream
hier.
Also Werbung, wo man auf diesen Werbebutton drückt.
Wenn überhaupt kommt Werbung, wenn ihr einschaltet, weil ich da nix dagegen machen kann.
Aber ich hab noch nicht einmal Werbeknopf gedrückt.
Ich hab natürlich schon Werbung gezeigt, weil ich Sponsoring-Sachen in Streams hatte,
aber ich hab nie Werbung, Werbeunterbrechung gedrückt bisher.
Ja, das Werbeprogramm ist auch unsinnig.
Hast du eigentlich eine Ausbildung zum Systemintegrator?
Ich hab Systemintegration gelernt.
2007.
Ist schon ein bisschen her, ja.
Geht richtig aussprechen, ja, das wäre nicht verkehrt, geht richtig auszusprechen.
Also man sollte sich Shit aussprechen.
Nö, kenn ich nicht.
Ist das, ist das, ist das das von den Battlefield-Leuten, von den ex Battlefield-Leuten?
Ja, ist es, ist es, ist es.
Bekommt bisher gute Kritiken, okay, ist das rausgekommen schon?
An den ehemaligen DICE-Entwickler, Klaus Beter, zu dem er auf PC gestanden hat, okay, okay.
Alles klar.
Wäre doch cool, wenn die was auf die Reihe kriegen.
Man, DICE hat es ja nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt die letzten Jahre, wäre doch gut, wenn die
jetzt was Neues, wenn die jetzt was Neues schaffen.
Ich habe übrigens irgendwas heute gelesen, das habe ich nicht ganz gecheckt.
Vielleicht blicken da irgendwelche TikTok-Enjoyer von euch durch.
Ich habe gelesen, es gibt einen neuen TikTok-Trend, dass man bei irgendeinem Kinofilm und nur
bei einem bestimmten Kinofilm mit Cola, mit Colaflaschen gegen die Leinwand werfen soll,
so lange bis der Film abgebrochen wird.
Was zum Teufel ist da auf TikTok wieder los?
Creed, möglich, ja, du hast recht, Creed 3, warum und warum, warum, also plickt das
irgendjemand, hat irgendjemand eine Ahnung warum, weil die dumm sind, okay, das ist natürlich
die ultimative Erklärung für alle TikTok-Geschichten, aber wo kommt, was ist da wieder los, man?
Es ist immer noch ein besserer Trend, es ist immerhin noch ein besserer Trend, als Wäschetaps
essen.
Das war wirklich so die Krönung und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was gleichzeitig der dümmste
und tragischste Trend überhaupt war, von dem ich, von dem ich, von dem ich so direkt
gar nichts mitbekommen habe, aber man hat die Opfer, die Opfer gesehen, also das war,
es gab auf TikTok eine Ich erhänge mich Challenge, es war nicht wirklich eine Ich erhänge mich
Challenge, man muss sich mal vorstellen, alle TikTok, die sind wirklich, trennen komplett,
trennen komplett ab, es gab, es gab eine Challenge, da ging es darum, sich selber, sich selber
bewusstlos zu würgen oder so und das ist ein Schwachsinn, muss man sich mal vorstellen,
wenn man das schon, wenn man das schon ausspricht, stellt man fest, wie unglaublich bescheuert
das alles ist, so und ich habe das nur mitgekriegt, weil es vor einer Weile eine größere Diskussion
um Lebenserhaltende Maßnahmen, war das glaube ich, gab in England und da gab es ein Kind,
das lag jetzt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zwei Jahre oder so mit Hirntod im Krankenhaus und
da habe ich mir mal die Geschichte zu durchgelesen, das hat sich selbst quasi für eine TikTok
Challenge so erhängt und die Mutter hat es halt gefunden, wo es zu spät war, kam das
Kind ins Krankenhaus, Hirn halt schon komplett hinüber und da ging es dann letztendlich
darum, ob die Geräte abgestellt werden dürfen und so was, es war eine riesen Geschichte
in UK und da geht es gar nicht so sehr darum, es ging jetzt um die TikTok Challenge, also
es gab wohl wirklich eine TikTok Challenge, wo die Leute sich selbst gewürgen sollten
bis zum bewusstlos werden und da muss man sich sagen, man kann sich doch schon überlegen,
egal wie jung und wie blöd man ist, dass die Sauerstoffzufuhr zum Gehirn abschneiden
nicht sonderlich gut sein kann, also ich meine, es ist doch gar nicht möglich, dass man nicht,
dass man das nicht merkt, dass es eine doofe Idee ist, das muss einem doch klar sein, ach
keine Ahnung, TikToks Zeug, ich blicke da nicht mehr durch, ja gut, das ist ja wieder
was anderes, sich mit Kleber an der Straße festkleben.
Was, was, künstlich hyperventilieren, nee, nee, nee, nee, es gab, nee, nee, aufs Herz
drücken musst du nicht, es gab ein Trend, wo die Leute hyperventiliert haben im Liegen
und dann schnell aufgestanden sind, sodass sie bewusstlos werden, das haben sie gefilmt,
das ist unglaublich, es ist so unglaublich dämlich, das ist so bescheuert man, aber
die Wäschetaps-Challenge war schon auch absolute Krönung von TikTok Trends bisher, ja, meine
Güte, ja, zu sechst im Vorstellungsgespräch, mal gucken, hoffentlich schwätzen sie dich
nicht so voll von allen Seiten gleichzeitig, haben da bisschen Struktur drinne, ah, du machst
das schon, ich mein, du hast ja hoffentlich Ahnung von dem Thema, das kannst du denen
ja auch ruhig verkaufen, dass du Ahnung von dem Thema hast, ansonsten, tja, achso, wir
wollten ja ein Video gucken, fällt mir gerade ein, kann man Anwendungen, die auf einem Container
eigentlich mit Anwendungen, die auf einem Container, Clustern oder Notebalancing, ja, kann man,
also sprich nix dagegen, das zu machen, also rein, von der Machbarkeit her, geht doch so
klar, warum soll das nicht gehen, was machst du, aktuell bist du im Projektleiter, oh,
Gottes Willen, bloß nicht, wenn du wissen willst, was ich beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber
mache, guck einfach mal, ich habe auf YouTube, ja, sowas habe ich gemacht, warum, ich habe
relativ viele Videos zu dem Thema schon gemacht, kannst dich auf YouTube mal umgucken, da ist
das auch alles ein bisschen ausführlicher, was ich erzählt habe, aber ich bin glücklicherweise
kein Projektleiter, und ich habe auch keine Ambitionen Projektleiter zu werden, so, wir
müssen jetzt aber das Video noch gucken, weil, sind ja nur 7 Minuten, Lul, wir fangen noch
von vorne an, guckt euch mal an, richtig, ein richtig nicer Kacona Stecker, ja, ich
glaube, das ist jetzt ein Clip, ich dachte, das ist irgendwas von früher, ja, das ist
jetzt ein Clip, ich dachte, das ist irgendwas von früher, ja, Nightbot hat bei mir auch
ein paar Aussätze auf das Mal,
ich
right at the us capitol i know this just went zero to 101 sentence but this was the reason
why he was removed as the face of the emote on twitch that's where i believe the very very beginning
of the end for better ttv started as in reaction to twitch removing the emote franker phase z
removed every pogchamp emote variant basically any imagery with goo tex's face in it was off
their extension besides pog that one stayed with better ttv saying that they will not be removing
any pog emotes in general better ttv has never removed emotes due to controversies and likely
won't as a result of this behavior ja das ist der grund warum wir noch manche pog emotes
im chat benutzen können wegen der twitch theory choice on our platform in retrospect this was
the right choice for better ttv because during this time all the big streamers wanted to seem
like they were doing a big service to the streaming community by changing their pogchamp emotes to
something different only for them to all flip back to using goo tex emotes like four months later
but that statement they released would also backfire on them because in february of 2021
better ttv decided to remove the emote zulo off their website now this one i definitely agree
should have been removed i mean look at it man after its removal it was promptly replaced
with a new zulo but because of that something in the dark depths was cooking something was brewing
in the spring of 2021 a new extension would be making the rounds around smaller streamers chats
7 tv and reaction to the emotes better tv was removing this extension was created now the big
reason why i said it was immediately said okay that was also one of the reasons why i made a
bigger curve around 7 tv now it's supposedly better
kohler abgedrückt
features 7 tv brought to the table like zero with emotes allowing you to stack emotes on top of each other and name paints for further customizability okay that's actually quite cool that was enough to convince quite a lot of people to download the extension the problem with the extension at launch was truly it didn't take itself too seriously causing some questionable emotes to be plastered all over the website or hidden private emotes only visible if you visited the user's profile there was so much potential for this extension to take off and be better than any extension available and
after some criticism they took it to heart because they got to work almost immediately fixing the emote
issues and moderation problems slowly but surely the number of users on the website began to grow
and it grew enough to where it was time to start getting emote integration on the other extensions
emote integration allows users to install only one of the main emote extensions but will still be able
to see all three of the extensions this is where things get funky
they easily got the integration now for better ttv in various chats 7 tv users were asking better tv devs about emote integration this could be chalked up to just general shit talk and it wasn't directly from the creator night but a few staff members were pretending they didn't know what 7 tv was which doesn't make sense considering they are better tv staff members like you would think you would know or catch wind of the new extension that everyone is talking about on october 9 2022 this little twitter thread would be the start of a little tiny beef between the
creator of better tv night and the creator of 7 tv anatole moment es gibt ernsthaft beefs zwischen chrome add-on creaton
and emotes are finally here you can now upload emails with up to three times more width from your dashboard dead app 7 tv on top yeah but 7 tv is taking away too much
information about you and your viewers so i would not recommend to use 7 tv is taking away too much information about you
okay also sprich er sagt da ist quasi so tracking eingebaut tv from what i've heard they have bots which sit in all the twitch chat collecting data and when the bots get banned it rejoins on a different account i.e.
you can't get rid of it dude your extension has an option to see the chat while banned a bot rejoining on anon is no different
speak about unethical while your service literally demands hundreds of dollars for that same month
under what i believe was now the lead promotional tweet from twitch night would be seen under that
tweet throwing more shade at 7 tv this sure looks like ban evasion to me which is definitely against
the at twitch community guidelines it's surprising twitch streamers slash viewers continue to promote 7 tv
given their unethical practices this response is not what you'd expect from a company acting with
good intent now all this shit talk only ever started once 7 tv began to become a real threat
financially to better tv that's when night started this little campaign to shit talk and i'm sure he
thought it would go amazing i mean he created better tv he must have all the twitch ogs by his side
he ended up nuking his whole twitter page and has been extremely silent since this encounter up
until january 18th of 2023 huge massive gargantuan update for better tv dropped i am not exaggerating
when i tell you this one to one bar for bar they stole every single feature that made seven tv
unique loyalty badges larger emote slots emote renaming and they changed their logo to a scuffed
ass punch studios wer hat denn jetzt von was geklaut better twitch tv hat von 7 tv oder wie geklaut
logo the most interesting addition though was what's this 7 tv support has it finally happened
have all the emote extensions made peace and we can finally live happily ever after well when
ticking the 7 tv box you are met with a very backhanded message disguised as a very heartfelt
warning from what i can't help but assume was written by night himself over one million users
in almost two years and every big streamer having the extension enabled in their chat
i believe it is safe to say there is a new king of twitch emote extensions
ja easy ja so lange die ihre moderationsprobleme in griff gekriegt haben mache ich das
mit consistent updates und ein eurer der nicht versuchte brüchen zu brennen
statt in der Vergangenheit war er hoffnungsvoll für eine welt wo alle extensions zusammenarbeiten können
aber klar mit dem nicht möglich sein sieben tv hat sich selbst in der twitch historie als der
erste neue emote extension zu erzielen beim brechen in den scenen und auch die twitch
space by expanding on the whole idea of an extension and for them it's worked quite well
i don't believe better tv will ever fully die but the stunts performed by night
have truly put a stain on the entire legacy of better tv
schon irgendwie sas
oder china chinesen das kann natürlich auch sein ja auch möglich auch möglich
ich glaube es ist bettgetime oder nicht wie seht ihr das sieht es sieht nach 22 uhr 8 aus
was heißt sieht nicht nur nach 22 uhr 8 aus sieht nach 22 ist auch 22 uhr 8
musst du morgen arbeiten ja ich muss montags nicht arbeiten freitags muss ich arbeiten und
das wird beim neuen arbeitgeber auch so sein und morgen fahre ich sogar noch mal nach frankfurt
let's check in irgendwas vergessen hab im chat post jam
ja ne hab ich nichts übersehen ja welche denn ich sehe keine
er macht sommer ist das wurde chain law gebannt das ist ein neuer account vom chain law hier
das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen ok ne du bist kein account von chain law du bist 2013
gejohnt und bis seit 2017 am starten hast über 1000 nachrichten geschrieben nee ok du bist nicht
du bist nicht 2.0 ich glaube ich hab dich auch schon aber der chain law ist normalerweise
der einzige dieses ausrufe zeichen frage sinnlos spammt wo ist er eigentlich da habe ich jetzt den
letzten zwei streams nicht gesehen normalerweise ist er immer am start und spammt irgendwelche
sinnlosen dinger rum oder oder postet irgendwelche monka toss subreddits und so was oder so was ja
ok leute wir sehen uns ist den macht es gut zu